[Music]
Selena Gomez and Justin Bieber have a
long history together you look guys I do
too sometimes they're like I want all of
you forever and other times I'm done I
don't deserve this I really do not
deserve this I'm Deidre Behar we're
running down everything we know about
the dynamic duo's complicated past on
New Year's Eve in 2009 Justin made the
first move serenading Selena on Dick
Clark's New Year's rockin Eve special
[Music]
[Applause]
Selena denied any romantic feelings on
Ellen in 2010 but in 2011 they made
their red carpet debut at the Vanity
Fair Oscar party and Ellen got the real
scoop he's sweet as can be but he's not
like your little brother is he the
couple attended a handful of events
together but ultimately split for the
first time in November 2012 I'm saying
oh yeah you're fine good a few months
later they were spotted at the 2013
Billboard Music Awards a backstage
camera gave us this now iconic moment of
Taylor Swift expressing her true
feelings about their reunion in 2014
they were spotted vacationing together
in Canada but soon after Selena hinted
there was trouble in paradise on Twitter
this marks the second time they split
November 2014
Selena released her most emotional song
to date inspired by their painful
breakup
[Music]
in 2015 there both singled but continued
to talk about each other
Selena told refinery29 she was quote
heartbroken
while Justin described their
relationship too complex
explaining quote it was a marriage kind
of thing we were so in love do you take
each other I do
Justin even had some clever hidden
imagery in his video for where are you
now
despite Justin serenading Selena at a
hotel piano bar in LA
in November 2015 he confused us all when
he started dating models like Haley
Baldwin and Sophia Ricci shortly after
in January 2017
Selena started dating the weekend but
after 10 months of romance the source
confirmed their split to ET could you
give us some privacy for like one second
here's where Justin comes into the
picture again the pair connected as pals
not long after Selena revealed she
underwent a kidney transplant in
November they enjoyed a bike ride
together and Selena was spotted wearing
Justin's hockey jersey after supporting
him at a game it's adorable so fetch the
million dollar question here is Jelena
back on let's talk about it over on
Twitter I'm at Deidre Behar
[Music]